nascere un paese o una casa con la
famiglia non me ne so per me è un regalo
enorme e mio padre aveva 20 mallya o più
di cinquanta fratelli a casa mia e via
vai delle persone che vuole possono
condividere quello che abbiamo in casa
mia per mio padre è normale vedere la
gente intorno a noi e spesso vedo il mio
padre non c'era il suo cibo a dare le
persone noi che siamo i suoi figli siamo
preoccupati richiedendoli papa ma perché
fai queste cose qua perché non tieni
tutto per noi perché noi siamo i tuoi
figli e le un giorno ci ha risposto sì
voi se ti ami i fili ma io vorrei
rimanere in questo modo ed ha vissuto
quella cosa che avete bisogno
ma prima o poi la moto mi potrà via
lontano da voi
e quando cosa questo cosa capiterà voi
farete da soli e io spero soltanto una
cosa quando stretto in un vostro strade
da soli
troverete a qualcuno che vedrà un pezzo
di pane o un bicchiere d'acqua che lo
darà ma non proprietà ma perché ha visto
qualcosa di buono in voi questo è mio
padre
e così è stato io sono arrivato a parma
quando sono arrivato a parma aspettavo
un pezzo di pane bicchiere d'acqua
come diceva mio padre invece ho avuto
molto di più
sono stata notata parma e sono la figlia
di questo famiglia meraviglioso e tutto
quello che un ophelia può desiderare
mi hanno dato ringrazio ogni genitore
oltre questo limite nei suoi hanno
preoccupato per me preoccupati poiché
sono non ho lo stesso colore da lodi il
loro colore è un bel giorno meno
chiamato da pate hanno detto bali quando
esce da questo cancello la vita non sarà
lo stesso perché la gente ti giudicano
ma no perché tu hai fatto qualcosa di
male ma va il colore della tua pelle
io non riesco a capire questo dico
pecchia mamma non è non sarà così fa
vorrei spiegare di più ma sarà così
ed è così è stato
spesso tornava a casa raccontare i miei
genitori l'insulto le cose che mi dicono
e raccontando questo faccio a stare male
anche a loro quando ho capito questo
smesso di raccontare tutto loro ho
tenuto tutto dentro di me molto volta
torna a letto con questo cose rabbia
tristezza qualsiasi cosa che sia cieco
di trovare un modo per perdere questo
cosa che mi hanno trasmesso durante la
giornata sono andato avanti rimango
sempre lì intorno a casa intorno al
parma con loro ma spesso delle cose
belle e mi succedono perché con i
genitori e andiamo fare shopping durante
weekend e durante questo shopping le
commesse quando provò a qualche abito mi
chiedono mi chiedevano ma tu fai la
modella io dico di no e chiedono anche
media nei tre le fa la morale i genitori
no lei non facciamo delle le nostra
figlia dicevano i genitori ma a furia di
sentire queste parole modella moderando
il giotto mamma spiegami cosa vuol dire
modella perché sono curiosa e allora mi
hanno detto per fa la modella bisogno
sarai tacco 15 tout va in giro solo
scappa dal cd colors capra ginnastica
allora anch'io voglio saperlo usa e tabù
attacco 15 intorno a parma abbiamo
chiesto dove ci sono qualche scuola
ricompattamento dove posso imparare
terminale su tacco 15
e così è stato sono entrato questo
ambiente intorno a parma facevo mio
lavoro tranquillamente per un bel giorno
qualcuno arriva da milano
vedendo amici quella che esce con un
ragazzo come t a milano io come me come
fa con la letto bene andiamo sono a casa
racconta tutto ai miei genitori dico
mamma perché se con un ragazzo come me a
milano fa vabbè loro dicono no a milano
non ci vai perché pericoloso perché cioè
devo andare a milano da sola io ho fatto
di tutto sono andata a milano sono
arrivata a milano
e questa agenzia un'agenzia più
importante della città abbiamo appreso
le mie misure due foto mi hanno mandato
a casa ma qualche giorno dopo mi hanno
richiamato dicendomi puoi tornare a
milano perché il lavoro è preso come
cominci lavora con noi
e questi sono entrato in quest'ambiente
dei abc meraviglioso delle cose che oggi
mi mancano un po poco
ma non tanto è andato avanti questo
questo ambiente
tutto sempre favolosa è favoloso finché
non aveva 25 anni quando 25 anni le cose
comincia a diventare l'ambiente cambia
perché sono entrati casting a reggio
cast in dialetto vede una ragazza
piccolo che arriva già al mela poi dopo
mi chiedono quanti anni ho 25 26 27
cross e cara abbiamo bisogno di new
faces le ragazze giovane io sono vecchia
per rimanere in quest'ambiente
questo cosa fa male fa davvero male e
devo cercare di sopravvivere in questo
ambiente ma in cui in italia è
impossibile per farlo devo uscire
dall'italia ho chiesto in giro dove se
dovessi la possibilità per me
prescrivermi come modella mi dicevano
germania l'uomo ovunque ci conoscevamo
da io andavo perché volevo vedere cosa
c'era tra parte è sì l'altra parte c'e
la differenza è un modo di lavorare di
destra mi accoglievano come sono io mi
prendevano per lavoro quello che so fare
se non dava bene dicevano che non mano
per il mio colore
faccio questo vita con l'acqua in giro
al mondo sono arrivato in america un bel
giorno
in america c'è un amica anche questo
momento mi chiamò a bali ci vediamo per
pranzo ios e molto volentieri ma prima
di arrivare a pranzo andiamo fare fitti
fitti e la prova che tutti noi vorremmo
fare prima di indossare l'abito per
giorno dopo e la compagna questo mia
amica fra il fiji finisce di fare figli
su casting ha retto wada anche me mi fa
ci vogliamo la sfilata io ho dentro di
me mi volete la sfilata
guarda che qui non solo un'agenzia noi
c'è un cast da letto non sono da solo e
con questo poi in questo paese non ci
preoccupa noi ci vogliamo questo per me
e non potevo immaginare dove arrivavo io
dove avere quello quello quello che
tante altre cose e giorno dopo mi trovo
lincoln senza non so chi sa la storia di
moda conosci all'incontro
lincoln center o il sogno di tutte le
modelle a rivoli guado so quello che
succede intorno a me le modelle di tutti
i paesi e qualsiasi età perché ho
chiesto loro anziani avevano hanno quasi
quarant'anni e lavoravano in
quest'ambiente erano felice io da
lontano o altro tutto quello che c'era
lì ognuno di noi avevamo qualcosa di
speciale perché avevamo detto allora è
di origine diversi con una mia albergo
mi sono chiesto ma perché io in italia
non posso essere me stesso ma perché non
posso stare in paese dove se una persona
che mi vuole bene fare il mio lavoro
però qua in america io posso fare story
però io posso essere una donna
conosciuto in america ma è quello che
vuoi prete bali
ho capito che non è quello che voglio io
io non voglio solo story il mondo io
voglio stare bene ovunque mi trovo a
mondo quello stare bene e presto e bene
non posso rimanere qui e lì ho deciso io
torno a casa
si torna a casa gli ottomani italia è
così sono tornato in italia prima a me
se la spaventosa perché non so dove
cominciare
allora qui l'italia io so non era di
colore [ __ ] web agcom i capi a bari
ovviamente ci sono le persone di colore
come me che fanno progetti offro io
prendo la mia macchina ovunque
progettiamo vado vado vado vado a vedere
ovviamente quando arrivò li vedo la
wally ady siria black qui a strong cui
anch'io afro italia a essere sola nera
però nessun momento ho capito che non
c'è la voglia di collaborazione fra
queste cose qua e ovviamente capisco
capisco perché noi che siamo qua di
colore vogliamo farci vedere che noi
diciamo anche anche con la parte bella
non solo con la parte che sentiamo tv
c'è quella pazza li avevamo voglia di
gridare questo pad è talmente a foto e
che guarda che siamo tanto vogliamo
rimanere acqua vogliamo pagare le tasse
come fa come facciamo tutti i giorni
vogliamo fare cose belle cose però io
quel momento gli ho detto non è quello
che vuole anche qua io voglio qualcosa
di più cosa faccio torna a casa penso
ancora un po e chiamò tutte le mie
amiche ex mai diventati eksmo di noi
siamo più ma delle perché abbiamo 30
anni chiamando tutti a loro dicendo a
loro io sono incinta rico cose perché il
progetto alle quali sono i cesari una
cosa più importante di me ma ho bisogno
di voi che aiutati a miracle questo cosa
insieme e vediamo dove possiamo portarlo
raccontando la mia idea e le abbiamo
messo capito che la strada che volevo
prendere è veramente importante e per la
prima volta in italia a milano 25 aprile
2014 abbiamo creato questo progetto dove
c'erano designer italiano designer
africano e un design al filippino
rimaniamo sempre l'abbiate l'amore
perché noi non sappiamo fare altro che
moda la nostra esperienza è lì intorno a
noi abbiamo organizzato una sfilata dove
sono le modelle di tutto il mondo dove
ci sono questo design l'unica
preoccupazione che avevamo in quelle
zone e speriamo che capisco la nostra
idea
noi avevamo voglia di condividere la
nostra cultura
le esperienze che abbiamo ricevuto in
quest'ambiente
volevamo farli vedere che noi la moda lo
vediamo anche un po così non solo in
modo che noi siamo cresciuti
vogliamo fare un nuovo a chi avvicino
alla gente l'amore che la gente poi sono
sentirsi comodo seduti e center a
qualcosa
con questo modo è per fallo ognuno di
noi abbiamo perso il nostro core li
abbiamo messo insieme perché io sono
nata e nigeria si ma sono cresciuto in
italia
ora la possibilità di girare il mondo io
non posso prendere solo una bandiera
io anche se ho questo colore sia
qualcosa in più
dentro questo colore e non posso fare
morire questo cuore e se io conosco la
moda si sono cresciuto non abbia nella
moda vuole usare quello che so fare per
fare capelli questo paese questo
ambiente che io vorrei vedere un po più
meltin'pot il mondo e noi abbiamo
lavorato più di design a che arrivano da
tutto il mondo
a milano con diversi cuccioli ei codici
mio paese è importante come la vostra
noi vogliamo mettere tutti i quali
insieme per fare qualcosa di positivo è
così abbiamo creato il core a ruota io
ho scelto e corea dword perché ho scelto
il mondo però che ancora
[Musica]
[Applauso]